[Music]
you hear a lot about this person and
then when you actually get to know them
or play with them they turn out to be a
little less than what you expect he
actually turned out to be much more and
turned out to be like the absolute
mildew never in the history of
competitive dota has there been a
captain as revered I always wanted to
play the puppy because he's like one of
the best captains innovative and
permanent as puppy I've been playing
dota my whole life and playing on this
stage comparison to the other stages I
still love it it's still amazing I'm
gonna keep coming despite the
controversy he's invoked hooking conch
for players with Chen teleport was one
most amazing things that I've done and
the criticism he's invited puppey
commands a respect that few others can
muster and remains quite possibly the
game's single most influential and
enduring thinker this is his story
[Music]
clement puppey Ivanov was born in 1990
in Tartu Estonia even in his youth he
knew that he wanted nothing more than to
spend his life immersed in cerebral
activities all I do is spend my time on
playing that computer
and I don't take anything seriously
anymore from the social world like
school or something like that placing
more value on his musical and gaming
education than a Scholastic one puppy
started competing in video game
tournaments at 13 and attended the hey
no Ehlert are to music college I myself
believe that knowing music was more
important than school in addition to
becoming a talented guitarist he learned
to play the saxophone flute clarinet and
drums he also developed a talent for
language acquisition becoming fluent in
Russian and English in addition to
Estonian but with intelligence and
individualism comes dissidents I myself
believe that earning more money somehow
through a game like poker was way more
important that's cool from an early age
puppey knew that he wasn't cut out for a
normal 9 to 5 job whether he was
shredding solos in his death metal band
or competing in defense of the ancients
competitions puppey wanted to challenge
and be challenged I then I really care
about the social norms I was confident
that school was not my path and I used
that confidence to you know go my own
way he played a handful of tournaments
between 2007 and 2008 but it wasn't
until he stood in for Maus at Dreamhack
winter 2008 that puppey met the player
who to come both his teammate and good
friend Kuro Kuro key soul a he taka so
me when we went to DREAM Act 2008 I
think
I met puppy-like before that some weeks
and then he stood in and riemeck because
eh couldn't come and that's where I met
papi and if I dream like we got first
place and then we decided to make a team
together
papi played with kuroky on King surf
International where they edged out meet
your makers in the dota League Masters
final the two went on to play for
nirvana International which eventually
became GG dotnet before Poppi was
invited to join one of the CIS a--'s
most dominant teams Navi with the launch
of Valve's highly anticipated dota 2 on
the horizon puppey accepted prompting
kuroky to publish a now-famous blog post
lamenting his dear friends departure
little did puppey know his decision to
join na'vi
marked the beginning of yet another
significant partnership this time with
the most famous player in the game's
history daniel dendi ishutin his moves i
think are unique and they might win you
the game but he wants to rely completely
on skill he wants like an enemy against
him and he wants to kill him through
skill nothing more it was to win the
game with the arrival of dota 2 came the
advent of the International a valve
hosted tournament whose first iteration
boasted an unprecedented 1.6 million
dollar prize pool na'vi went into TI as
western favourites and went undefeated
all the way to the finals
[Applause]
now Nami there aren't they going to take
the chance in they couldn't go in from
the GGN TT is Nicole from hate white
hood
none of the already own thing computers
but not even sticking around
Navi onto the grand finals and will play
and yet unlike the tournament's other
grand finalists Chinese powerhouse be
home it wasn't their strategy or
discipline that made Navi such a force
to be reckoned with
it wasn't even their skill necessarily
it was their wildness their
unpredictability their confident yet
nonchalant attitude and above all their
ability to just well win
[Music]
to take home 200
we are the champions and so began the
Golden Age of Navi this team has been
more about playing dota instead of
making a legacy isn't that and I think
it's pure in this sense after winning
the biggest tournament in the history of
eSports
puppey was entrusted to take over the
drafters chair from art style as dendi
started to solidify himself as the most
dominant and popular mid laner
in the world there was never a time
where we weren't really dominating
puppey led his team to seven first-place
finishes
between TI 1 and 2 na'vi entered the
second international as not only
defending champions but the most
accomplished and beloved dota team in
the world the international 2 is like
whatever you achieved then you have to
repeat it I think it has much much more
pressure it's like you've done it before
and I'll do it again and despite their
middling performance in the group stage
Navi traversed the winner's bracket all
the way to the grand finals there they
met Chinese Dark Horse Invictus gaming
this year the enemy is much much
stronger people are ready to face us
they're not scared of us because more
teams have actually gone above us and
skill but whatever you have in skill
does not really matter if the team
itself is like spiritually like ready so
it all depends on like the team it was
in these finals that na'vi executed the
single greatest teamfight maneuver in
the history of dota referred to solely
as the plan they storm up the river
patience from so waiting in the wave now
he is about to be caught oh there's the
sleep that sir
he catches everyone oh this could be a
total
my daddy
that's why I'm trying to survive [ __ ]
gonna go down puppey talked about the
nagas counter it's why the Bevin what
this BKB they turn it around
unfortunately it wasn't enough
IG were the stronger team and Navi went
on to lose the final three to one
despite his best efforts
puppey had fallen short of a second TI
title throughout the 2012-2013 season
puppey led his team to a whopping 10
first-place finishes
part of na'vi sustained dominance came
from puppy's decision to enlist the help
of an old friend
kuroky we both want to do something that
is just like magical things but the most
core point is that we both really love
the game enough to just make art out of
it na'vi were still considered to be one
of the most dominant teams in the world
but they were no longer considered the
sole european threat a new western
talent had arisen the Alliance the
reason why everyone fears us is because
we can never really know what we're
gonna do and we will sometimes switch
our playstyle led by captain and rafter
Gustav s for Magnuson the all Swedish
lineup had taken the dota scene by storm
I like how as for place he's a real team
player and I I wish him the best because
he has really done some amazing things
in my eyes he has started to play a
different way and everybody else started
to go his way also boasting seven
first-place finishes of their own they
were considered the best team in the
world winning this year's international
it'd just be so awesome they would just
be a proof that we we were the best team
this year and and I would just be so
happy for the other guys in the team as
well
na'vi finished first in their group with
an 11 and 3 record but alliance had
toppled the other group with a
staggering 40 Nando finish Navi would go
on to challenge the Swedes in the upper
bracket final but not before facing off
against tongfu in a series that would go
on to become the most controversial in
the history of competitive dota 2 after
trading evenly in Games one and two
puppey kicked off Game three by drafting
he and andis signature heroes Chen and
Pudge now all they pick it they put the
pledge you can see dendi smiling right
now after falling significantly behind
the two players had no choice but to get
creative the game was on the edge and we
could lose it like any moment I was sure
about that we knew we needed to do
something so we started to try something
else then he said this is the only way
we can win the game us too just doing
that stupid stuff I was like alright
let's go
& tongfu is going to continue to push
they're not done Mac still hasn't even
been used there's a hook how run all the
way back to the base
flared up by the fountain by combining
pudges hook ability with Chen's teleport
Navi were able to hook enemy heroes into
navi's own fountain even going so far as
to delete an aegis wielding gyrocopter
the fountain for fountain could continue
yeah why not yeah why not just keep it
up fountain the hooking didn't just
inspire hope with the Navi it enabled
them to close the gap on what should
have been an insurmountable lead there
we go the hook goddess
Navi had beaten tongfu but at what cost
some viewed na vi's decision to make
continuous use of the exploit as a
stroke of genius you have to respect the
skill that it took for those fountain
hooks to happen if it was completely
broken and super easy to do everyone
would be doing it they weren't afraid to
try it or make it happen others were
vocal about it any bug abuse I'll say
angry watching the game it's not really
so much against Navi that's against the
rules
you guys don't deserve it or something
like that you know like whatever dude
whichever side one falls on there is no
question that fountain hooking z'
simultaneously incredible and
incredulous debut on the world stage
will always be remembered as one of
puppy's most significant contributions
to competitive dota hooking tomfool
players with gen teleport was one of the
most amazing things that I've done it
was vicious and I was part of it
Navi went on to get swept by Alliance in
the upper bracket final and after
earning a fortuitous win against orange
eSports in the last round of the lower
bracket secured a spot in the grand
finals of an international for the third
year in a row this is an amazing moment
because I've been here for the third
time already and yeah that's pretty good
the rematch between Navi and Alliance
that ensued was legendary
framed as a battle of wits between puppy
and s4 the series saw both teams earn
two wins apiece before bringing it to
one of the greatest game fives ever
played everything hangs in the balance
it all comes down to this
one more game Navi got off to a
tremendous start
and as denby's strategically selected
Templar assassin continued to snowball
the prospect of Alliance's victory
looking for more he got melts right
funding i want to tender way by egm but
the trap won't a hit and no you will not
a gem will survive if not be win this
game they will be the first team in the
history of dota 2 to win two
internationals as na'vi finished off
alliances mid barracks and with s fours
teammates closing in for the split push
the swedish mid laner did the only thing
he could think of to halt lobby's
retreat that's what's gonna try to
cancel as many as possible
yo cancel three my god but Nick's gonna
try to TP butts gonna defend against
everybody me what load up and working on
the melee rax on the part of reality rip
it off funny you're getting stuck or
he's going to get back out for the
braixen huge triple they will defend
along
the first time s4 did it it earned his
team a two racks advantage the second
time which has since been dubbed the
million dollar dream coil it won them
the international he's got be kidding me
but no boots of travel but it's poets
now they go for the throne it could be
game the Knicks down Alliance I'm doing
it they need a little farm stuff all in
jeopardy doesn't live it could be their
last stand
then these back he's gonna try to focus
everybody but there's so much stuff the
place there's no more clubs available
10th of a half HP a cordage be a lion
surround him from all sides can be they
won the round they're gonna do it
not only had na'vi failed to win another
international they had gotten within an
inch of victory and given it away in one
of the greatest series of dota 2 ever
played I love all of my fans I give them
autographs all the time and I can stay
as long as in the booth as I can
as humanly possible and let's say I love
dota 2 na'vi started the following
season with a bang securing five
first-place finishes but by April 2014
their results had started to taper off
going into ti4 they hadn't won a
tournament in three months and had only
finished top four in two of their last
seven events and yet in spite of na vi's
decline it was expected that puppy would
come through in the end
it even got to the point where the
community had developed a meme around na
vi's resilience responding to every one
of their losses with the claim that
puppy was simply saving strats for Ti as
far as the community was concerned na'vi
were incapable of not making the grand
finals but that year for the first time
ever they didn't I was kind of prepared
to lose I didn't feel that we we can win
like even if he would win cloud nine of
him we wouldn't go that far this
tournaments following na vi's awful run
at ti4 rumors began to circulate that
puppy had wanted to kick dandy for some
time but that the organization had sided
with the marketable mid laner over
puppey himself
there were times where I sought to kick
everybody I'm team Navi I guess it
wasn't even it wasn't even about like
Dendi or whatever like you were all on
that pot because nobody was doing
anything good puppy left Navi as a
result taking kuroky with him bringing
the Golden Age of Navi to an end within
three months he and kuroky had started
their own roster one whose aim was to
stand as DotA's most powerful player
owned organization basically s4 said
yo I will play a puppy place and we just
stand it up kind of like all four of us
are in then the last guy comes into and
whatever let's go you know and basically
make us a semi Union so we just figured
forget it let's just do it ourselves
completely and we went from there
puppies so-called mystery Squad hadn't
yet settled on a name so they came up
with what was supposed to be a
placeholder team secret needless to say
it's stuck in January 2015 an
opportunity presented itself to secret
frustrated with Peter PPD dagger evil
geniuses art or art easy babaev and
Ludwig zai Wahlberg were looking for an
opportunity to jump ship in preparation
for the mini TI that was the dota 2 Asia
Championships
it's like feels natural to be in this
team think my teammates are individually
they're the best right now in the world
secret managed to go 15 and oh and DA
sees group stage and made it all the way
to the lower bracket finals there they
played eg the very team from which they
poach zai and RTZ
surprisingly secret lost and the
so-called super team had to settle for a
third place finish
puppy going down to the split shot up
beer that okay this is a disaster secret
looks to be out of DAC 2015 on paper
secret were a super team but still
needed time to mesh and in the months
following DAC much to the chagrin of
their opponents secrets anticipated
dominance became a reality at secret are
your red bow
Brown dota 2 champions the first ever
undulation steam secret they are gonna
be your summit three champions
[Music]
after years of falling short at the
international the time had finally come
for puppy to once again reach the top
and he knew it
come on degrade Shastra watch team wig
relay say to him at the quarry we Varian
calculate a vitamin improvement EPA
pretty much top story Greta customers
name motor business analysts ideas per
theater secret performed well in groups
finishing eleven and three and then as
soon as secret walked out onto the main
stage disaster struck they're looking
for the jump in that got the play call
it's on to see what
perhaps for the TPM as well
[Applause]
there's the coaster desperately
is going to be nigh impossible for
secret massacred under the blazing guns
of ziwei a pet-ct wise
[Applause]
have done it thank you Oh secret and
the secret had been knocked into the
lower bracket from the get-go and while
they managed to beat Invictus gaming
two-to-one they would eventually fall to
virtus pro tournaments on team secret
they have been eliminated and finished
7th 8th at the International 2015 and
like that the impossible had happened
the fallout was horrific
Ziya left the team to go back to school
s4 returned to Alliance and arteezy
who had blamed Kuro for every aspect of
the team's demise went back to eg as for
Kuro stunningly enough puppey kicked him
from the outside it seemed as if puppy
had done everything right as if his
squabbling super team had failed in
spite of his best efforts in reality
puppey probably had played a part in his
team seismic self implosion but it would
be some time before that came to light
the end of TI 5 marked a significant
point in puppy's career for years he had
been revered as a walking talking DOTA
divinity a drafter who could never be a
witted and would never become outdated
and yet for the first time in his
professional career he had fallen far
below expectations that said secret
continued to put up excellent results
with pile I died
misery eternalenvy and pub star mid
laner we hide aside puppy went on to
secure a second-place finish at the
Frankfurt major before winning the next
major in Shanghai there's no getting up
try and get the tomb that does God go on
to get off the Cronus ear but until
eternal Evie go straight from atop a man
to TP salver Fatih he knows his bike
this could be liquid all dying is mine
controls the only one to be able to get
away to the side and TP out
it looks like cherries Godot go down as
well as Pompey runs him down one to 13
team secret the best performance they've
had so far and what a time to have it -
and there it is congratulations team
secret taking four in one of the most
dominant fashions we've seen in the
grand finals I know you're probably
excited but exactly how do you feel this
moment I feel supreme even without a
super team puppy was achieving great
results and preserving his reputation as
a world-class captain but when puppy got
another opportunity to elevate secrets
roster he took it out went whee-ha and
misery and back Kmart easy and this time
he brought universe with him to
everyone's surprise secret super team
maneuver proved even more disastrous the
second time around the team took an
unimaginable 13th 16th finish at the
ensuing Manilla major causing universe
to return to eg after only three months
with secret is a is a pretty humbling
experience I think when I went to secret
my intention was to make like this
really good team I've always just wanted
to be part of the best team and that's
what I tried to do when I went to secret
so I kind of made me realize that you
can't just put like five really great
players together and hope it works out
like being on a team is more than just
that so at ti6
puppey put up the single worst Ti
performance of his career after going 5
and 9 in groups secret landed themselves
in a lower bracket best of one against
LGD
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
two months for the secret of going
but it turned out that that loss
crushing as it was would prove to be the
least of puppy's problems sama Lucia TCO
Kuwata is commandest
what at Bizness spots shining any sonic
doom Alexia if say very degree walk if
she does not do Mesa but important
Austin if she occurred more with a
Tibetan Thomas privately in the wake of
Jackie eternalenvy mouths departure from
secret in October 2016 the player
published one of his most infamous blog
posts in it he accused puppy and the
director of team secret Kamal sat a CO
glue of mismanaging both clear winnings
and sponsorship earnings this prompted
misery to publish his own blog in
support of Envy's claims this wasn't the
first time that secret had been accused
of failing to pay its players in
February the team's former manager evany
Chang had posted a twit longer of her
own alleging that she and the team's
2014-2015 roster had gone two years
without being paid
what's more Envy accused puppy of being
an incredibly erratic leader one who
refused to practice drank heavily of
tournaments verbally abused his
teammates and underwent violent
outbursts in which he damaged equipment
the nail in puppy's coffin came in the
form of a leak a lengthy chat log
between he and secrets coach 14:37 had
been released to the public in it
puppey disparage his old friend and
teammate kuroky puppey released a
statement in response to the mounting
allegations but his decision to shy away
from them ended up doing more harm than
good
the community was left to reconcile the
stern but stylish strategist they had
long revered with the egotistical
unethical and irresponsible team owner
that envy and others had alleged him to
be puppy had lost the trust of the DOTA
community and his sterling reputation
all
with it and yet in spite of the ill will
he'd garnered puppy was determined to
keep both himself and secret alive
shortly after ti6 puppy recruited
Malaysian mid laner mid one who has
since solidified himself as a core
member of Secrets ever-changing roster I
always wanted to play with puppy because
he's like one of the best captains right
and I play a bit different dog like it's
more on rest inside and maybe it's most
suitable we've done that's why I chose
secret and then after months of relative
silence puppey posted a twit longer in
march 2017 detailing the ostensibly
earnest steps he and secret had taken to
make reparations for their past mistakes
about a month later secret recruited the
third member of its soon-to-be core
lineup superstar support yaps or by this
time the trauma around secret scandal
had started to subside come ti7
secret had put together a
salt-of-the-earth roster and we're
making strides to once again reach the
top tier puppy was steadily making his
way out of the community's doghouse and
it showed does he always do that
yeah that's kayo hissing before long
puppy had found himself facing off
against a kuroky lead liquid who were
about to make a faded climb through the
entirety of the lower bracket and win
the international altogether and I do
appreciate the run bait bit because like
I was part of that loss also for them to
annoy to living he was after narrowly
losing to liquid during secrets postgame
exit interview that puppy once again
earned the sympathy and respect of his
fans we've been on the road for a while
and you know when being on a roll for a
month with everybody there's gonna be
stressful moments arguments or whatever
whatnot we felt really good we almost
did it I think and
we really needed a little bit to win
this match and we don't know what would
have happened further but thank you for
supporting over the next year secret
gradually climbed to the top of the
competitive circuit they ranked fourth
in the 2017-2018 DPC and entered the
International eighth as mere favorites
secret style of play is hard to predict
easy to underestimate but devastating to
play against the fact that any one of
their players could be the star of the
match is what sets them apart from all
the other teams after losing to a
dominant eg in the first round of the
upper bracket they managed to beat vici
gaming and North American Dark Horse vgj
storm before losing to liquid in a
highly anticipated rematch jumps forward
and tries to take down one key and they
kill him off in time been one big cold
snap he doesn't have any way to get out
of there with a send back puppey keeps
it alive for the moment but still at the
tier three towers taken down that could
be just game over if he dies there amid
1 being safe once more my papi about how
they cannot save himself and now mid one
left alone there's going to be the
Cataclysm again who is imploring on it
miracle takes him down three dead no
buybacks given before and this is going
to be Gigi
go on
and again what more can you say about
this team I mean it looked like secret
really never had an opportunity to make
any type of moves in the last couple of
minutes lose game puppy had once again
fallen short of his dear friend kuroky
but this time it seemed as if the
hatchet was a little bit closer to being
buried you gotta love the respect fellow
captain's former teammates for the
seventh year in a row puppy had fallen
short of winning an international but he
had also for the eighth year in a row
made it to the International not only
that he managed to earn his team a top
six finish at TI ate the most cutthroat
tournament in the history of dota 2 it's
been up and down to be honest we started
a lot of snowballing going on right now
and I think liquid we NT I it's like
this right I think we had them by the
balls in the first game with the with
the draft you know it's like the second
game fine let's lose that one but we
should have won the first one it should
have been Game three and it should have
been like because they they have like
they outsmarted us in the second game
and chose something else right alongside
kuroky and Chinese veteran DDC puppey is
the only player to attend every single
international every TI has been amazing
so as this one but the difficulty the
difficulty is becoming very very very
hard he is in some intuitive undeniable
sense the player with the most
permanence in the history of dota with
that comes confidence but also an
unparalleled sense of perspective people
always say that I'm a good player
and that's the biggest value that I have
I don't lose interest and I'm playing I
don't become a coach I'm not even
looking towards though those directions
I'm only looking to the directions to
actually become a better player whatever
you think of papi he isn't just
deserving of respect he commands it
don't be scared right like what what
else you gonna do now
you're gonna lose or you're gonna win
what do you want to do you'll find that
confidence in you where you're gonna be
in 15 years are you gonna like look back
it's like oh I should have done
something you don't want to have those
feelings he's an old dog who's
constantly striving to teach himself new
tricks
a mural but cerebral competitor who
understands that being a legend takes
work
we need the moral fire so they start
yelling we started doing some stuff we
stood and started not caring and that
creates like some kind of true like fake
confidence let it be but it works it's
not clear how many more tea is puppy
will be around for what can be said with
absolute certainty however is that
however many there are whether 1 or 74
he'll be ready you're gonna be using a
walker to get out there on the stage to
play like TI 74 yea 74 is what I'm going
for
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]